happy holidays happy holidays Christmas
Eves part of one of those three holidays
right I think so Christmas Eve and
Christmas Eve and Christmas Day and
after Christmas Day Boxing Day oh yeah
that's why you're trying to fight me
earlier it's boxing that boxy black eye
is it is it just as boxing the Canadian
only or is it also I think it's in the
UK man that's big in the UK is it yeah
yeah because they like to fight man
anyway we wouldn't surprise you with a
non-scheduled surprise episode for
christmas and and so this episode is for
all of our listeners but it's three of
our favorite creations that we've put on
patreon over the last year we did a
bonus episode I think was number 10 I
think it's my favorite podcast that we
ever recorded period and I said we can't
just let no one hear this arm regular
audience how do we get this out but it
was only for patreon supporters and then
we did this great livestream in in
Dayton Ohio in which we we talked about
we talked about we just answered a bunch
of questions from patreon supporters and
so we'll put that in there we'll put the
audio from that it was a video obviously
if it's a livestream but then we'll put
the audio of that in there and then we
have one more episode we recorded in
Dayton Ohio it was a bonus episode in
which we we answer a lot of questions
that man it was oh by the way one thing
I should say there was a word that I
meant to say during that bonus episode
and it was well being we the the guy
asked to say how can minimalism help the
greater good and and what I was trying
to say is there are different levels of
well-being and so Shawn was a way for
you to insert that word well-being every
time I had screwed up and was searching
for that word but anyway otherwise it
was it was a great episode so we want to
share these three shorter episodes sort
of paste them all together and say Merry
Christmas Happy Holidays and
every other holiday whatever you
whatever you're celebrating we wanted to
give you this little audio gift for you
and if you do want to support the
podcast you can do so on patreon to
settle in over to the minimalists comm
and click donate at the top of the page
all right Happy Holidays y'all enjoy
this bonus episode of the minimalist
podcast
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me howdy good evening my
name is Larry I'm from Burnaby and
really appreciate you guys coming all
this way obviously you have a lot of
fans here and we appreciate the the
message that you have several months ago
I was listening to one of your podcasts
where you shared some of the the
criticism that you've received on social
media about the message that you have
and it was really quite entertaining and
rather shocking that so many people
rather than just simply ignore your
message would go well out of their way
to criticize what you have to say what
do you think is is the reason what what
buttons are you pushing or what's the
reason for this criticism that you would
receive on such a positive message that
you have I think I think the well the
the the short answer to that is
judgement is but a mirror that reflects
the insecurities of the person who's
doing the judging and and I think there
are two types of of I parse out
criticism from feedback and and I don't
just graciously accept feedback I seek
it out and you should from people who
whose opinions I value and so I will
seek out feedback because it makes
whatever I'm creating better
the reason our documentary was so
effective is because we were constantly
hammering at each other you know the
whole team going back and forth it
wasn't just one person's idea we were
all giving each other feedback and being
willing to accept that feedback and in
order to do that though you have to sort
of create a space in which an
environment in which you can thrive
otherwise you're just gonna get the
criticism which is is mostly noise yeah
man
I have the same question no you know I
think um I try to put myself in like
critic shoes because I really do want to
understand where people come from and
not just like brush it off and be like
well they're just jerks and you know
we're we're great in they're jerks like
I don't I don't I don't think that but
when I put myself in their shoes like
the only way I can really come to a
common ground is like everybody knows
that money doesn't buy happiness
but we all want to try it out just to
see and I think that it stems from a lot
of that where instead of someone and
I've been guilty of this so much of my
life instead of like looking at
something logically or stepping back and
looking at a situation like I will hold
on to a feeling and I think with the
people who you know really come after us
it's it's a matter of like they really
have the feeling of like no like having
a closet full of stuff it doesn't it is
gonna make me happy and it does make me
happy and having a yacht know that
really would make me happy and and they
hold on to that and you know what people
are entitled to their feelings but what
I'll say is just because someone is
offended it doesn't make them right
thank you thanks brother appreciate it
[Applause]
hi my name is Martha I'm from Kamloops
thank you so much for your story about
your mom because it was a real epiphany
for me I lost my parents in early 2000s
and I have six of the largest Rubbermaid
containers I could buy all of their
stuff and I recently saw your Netflix
show and it's made a huge difference and
it's allowing me to let go so thank you
thank you and then the next thing I
started decluttering and I'm really glad
you guys talked about values because one
of the things I'm struggling with is I'm
donating to Goodwill I'm giving to
friends but I've just got so much crap
that is gonna end up in the landfill and
I totally struggle without that sense of
not being responsible for my over
indulgences and I feel like it's not
right for me to just be able to abdicate
that responsibility and fill the
landfill and I just I really struggle
with that and I just wondered if you
guys have any ideas or whether you
struggled with that yourself yeah it's
already in the landfill yeah and I mean
it is and like I mean looking at it as a
sunk cost is probably the best
perspective you could have on it because
what's gonna happen you could hold on to
it great like and keep it out of the
landfill well you know I would say first
off well now it's decomposing slower
because it's sitting in your house but
then it eventually won't get rolled Yeah
right but it eventually will end up in
the landfill yeah I struggled with that
too because there were things were like
I couldn't donate I couldn't sell and I
couldn't recycle and I'm like man some
of this stuff is just gonna like end up
in the landfill just because I have
spent you know at that time I had spent
28 years really screwing up my life like
it I wasn't going to allow that to like
hold me back from living a meaningful
life after that
so yeah that sucks that you're gonna put
some stuff in the landfill but stop
doing that I'm sorry for your loss and I
know it's difficult to part with other
people's stuff that you have a
sentimental attachment with as well
so so a few things when I was getting
rid of stuff I put it into three piles
it was sell donate or trash but that
trash was sort of a catch-all for
several things one was can I recycle it
right or repurpose it in some way most
things you can donate and find a good
home for and so Ryan and I don't
advocate a zero waste lifestyle
to me that is pie in the sky and it
actually deters people from being
environmentally responsible and so what
we what what we're advocating is consume
less produce less waste and so going
forward I think that's what your mindset
is and I think it's important to
continue to maintain that but right now
that the waste is already there that
your your function at this point is
determine what is actually waste and
what can be repurposed reused resold and
then what you're going to have to let go
of
but yeah here's a pithy answer for you
you're gonna have to let go to move on
thank you so much you're welcome thank
you I know we have probably one zero
waste person in this crowd right now and
probably yet there she is really sorry
about the tickets
that screwed everything up for you I
know and I know there's people listening
to this I totally admire that lifestyle
by the way I I think that it is a it is
a very awesome thing to shoot for it is
it would be like me wishing that
everyone in the world would become a
minimalist it's you know it's just not
it's just not gonna happen but I totally
admire it and I'm totally
a voice of compassion here man who just
like totally going out to the zero-waste
folks uh I love you guys and like I'm so
happy that you all do that and I hope
that one day I can like minimize my
waist even more than what I do now
so yeah you're gonna be less my hair all
my hats off to all of you yes less
negative waste eat other people's trash
minimalism what's your name and where
you from I'm Kevin
howdy nice to meet you him from up the
street basically Kevin from up the
street
alright first I just want to thank the
guy that sold me his tickets and drove
down from northbound 10 minutes before
the show and Oh beautiful man
oh that's killer very cool whatever his
name is that yeah yeah so basically I
found out about you guys kind of before
summer and you know watched your thing
on Netflix kind of read your book so as
I start to declutter and get rid of all
the weed in my life I found out kind of
what was left is you know the
relationships my life and important
things and kind of the difficult part of
me now is wondering how do I deal with
the difficult decisions and how do I
deal with you know the there is weight
in relationships at the weight of other
people and other people's kind of
problems you know your family and people
close to you how do you guys deal with
that weight and what to let you know
sink into your kind of day-to-day and
what to kind of leave out like that's
kind of where I'm at right now Ryan
you're gonna tackle the relationship so
tackle the decisions yeah it sounds good
um man I I try not to air too much dirty
laundry of like my family's problems on
in public because I respect them and
like I know that they don't want me like
talking about their personal stuff I
will I will say this I think they'd be
okay with this I got a I have a brother
in prison right now he was addicted to
drugs and it led him to just committing
a lot of robbery were eventually guy
caught and like now he's in prison for
felonies and
that's just a tip of the iceberg in my
family man and and that's that there's a
lot of weight there and there's a lot of
weight with a lot of other things but
I'll tell you like the best the best way
I can help what I'm learning like the
best way I can help my family is by
being the best example possible and
living the most meaningful life possible
and when I started it didn't seem that
way because there's so much push back
and there was so much judgment that was
just being thrown my way because of the
website and you know me kind of pressing
against like everything that our Western
society is told to do and it took years
and years and years almost eight years
and years and years but it took years
like I'll say my mom she came out to
visit me and Missoula two years ago
for the first time maybe it was three
years ago and like when she when she got
out her her luggage the first thing she
did she like pulls out like this flower
vase and like some candles and I'm like
[ __ ] man like she's gonna give me a
present like like I mean you know it
wasn't that big of a deal as much as I'd
like in my head I'm like okay I feel
like oh this is great thank you and then
like you know I was gonna like donate it
or something but like before I could
even like really get the thought process
she was like hey here's some things I
got for you I know this is you and
Mariah's new home I love you I'm really
really proud of you for what you've done
and I just wanted to show you guys how
much like I am I am proud of you and I
understand that these things may not fit
well in your life but if they don't
that's fine like just find them find him
a good home for you know for me and that
was the first time it took up three
years until my mom finally was like oh
well III see where this is going I see
how this is this is benefiting your life
and and she respected it so I guess all
I can say is like all that baggage all
the baggage of my like my I will
literally get a phone call once or twice
a month with some in I could just value
with the crazy family stories Lee it's
always an emergency it's over the next
Syria and it's always an emergency
always an emergency and I'll tell you
I'm there I am supportive I am loving I
am kind but I will not let someone else
get in my way of living a meaningful
life Brian that reminds me of on episode
83 we had a friend of ours Rob Bell on
on the podcast and I think the advice he
would give you to distill it down is
you're gonna have to have a funeral for
the way you wish things were with those
other people and accept the way that
they are you know if I already give my
pithy answer it's you can't change the
people around you but you can change the
people around you but but you can also
accept what's going on for what it is in
terms of making a decision if you have
trouble making the decision about
something or if you're feeling
indecisive it's because you don't have
enough leverage and we we get we have a
whole lot of shoulds in our life I
should work out should improve my
relationships I should start writing
that book I should work on getting that
promotion I should start that hobby that
passion project I should contribute more
than I contribute I should read more we
should all over ourselves
and the only way to make a change to
make a real decision is to change that
should into a must and and you need the
leverage to do that think about a time
that you've made you've been so decisive
I'm going to do this I'm gonna start
today no more I can't wait until the
future it has to happen right now that's
because you had enough leverage and it
was no longer should you said I must do
this and I won't accept anything less
than then what I need to accomplish so
you turned those shoulds in the must
your you'll you'll be able to make a
decision really easily howdy hi my name
is Carolyn I'm from Burnaby welcome hi
so i i've been declaring my life
physical possessions mostly but now i'm
finding myself at a point where
detachment is almost like i've taken it
too far so I know that Joshua you
mentioned that when you're baked had
gone missing you're almost like oh
that's okay like you don't you weren't
so upset about losing that one Bay that
one black shirt you had that you brought
that was your extra shirt yeah
so for me I'm wondering if you have
advice for people that might have taken
Middleton too far in a sense of an
emotional attachment being detached from
certain personal relationships for
example I'm just thinking now I what if
that was the only shirt I had with me I
would be like why the hell you walking
around with your shirt why was it in
your bag guys you standing there making
your pants my OCD was flaring out so I
couldn't wear a shirt man I don't think
it's a bad thing to have like this this
radical detachment from the right stuff
and and usually that right stuff is
stuff you know when I say minimalism is
the thing that gets us past the thing so
we can make a room for life's most
important things you know sort of the
the triple entendre there but but what I
mean by that is the things are just
things right and you were not your
things
I'm not my passport or the black shirt
that got stolen or you know my car or my
house or whatever the thing should
augment our experience of life and when
I bring something new into my life I
need to be able to afford it that's
important right and even like losing
this stuff I could afford to replace it
because I have an emergency fund set up
right and so I've been really
deliberative about my finances over the
last six seven years and I've saved up
an emergency fund so I could deal with
emergencies like that that would be the
perfect use case for an emergency fund
it's you know being robbed as an
emergency and and so when I when I
detach I want to make sure that I'm
detaching appropriately and and and I
don't want to be detached from life I
want to be detached from giving meaning
to stuff yeah I think you said
specifically um detachment from
relationships so when it comes to
relationships it's part of my daily
practice like everyday like I'm asking
myself like how have I added value to
not just other people's lives but like
the people closest to me and I will go
way out of my way to show my partner
Mariah Josh
Jess Sean to show them like how much I
appreciate them and I think that's
important so I think that you certainly
could become too detached from people
and it would affect your life in a
negative way so for me like it's just
asking that question like how how can
you add value to the people who were
closest to you like what can you do for
them to show them that you truly love
them it might just be supporting him to
like it might just be listening to him
like with with like my mom it's just you
know calling her and keeping up with her
and I love the conversations we have and
sometimes she wants to like you know
rant about
crazy reptile people conspiracy theory
stuff I'm like yeah those reptile people
really screwed up the government it's uh
it's a big thing in America it's
unbelievable I'm kind of joking kind of
but no I mean it but you know even
sitting through something like that it's
like I know that me listening to my mom
is is really doing a lot for it she just
wants to be heard so if you're having
feelings coming up that's saying oh man
like I am becoming too disassociated or
unattached to the people around me and
it's like a visceral that guilt feeling
maybe like that's that is a that is a
signal for you to change that is a
signal for something to change now you
know don't feel guilty about it ten
years from now but yeah experience that
guilt and act on that and like ask how
can you how can you uh you know
reinvigorate that relationship or
whatever but yeah I I certainly because
as much as like Josh and I talked about
getting rid of shitty relationships and
you know cutting people out of your life
who are who are trying to prevent you
from living a meaningful life like I
still do stand by that but yeah you
certainly don't want one to get to a
point where you're you're just cutting
everyone out of your life I think
minimalism honestly well let me take a
step back there was someone in somewhere
in the UK but they're like minimalism
it's selfish it's all about it's all
about like focusing on yourself and
focusing on how you can improve your
life and you know so forth and so on
and I would say like that is that is the
start I think it is to improve one's
self but for me it was getting to a
point where like I finally felt like I
had enough time and attention after
minimizing and and reeling myself in
to give towards other people and I think
ultimately like that is what for me
that's what minimalism really comes down
to it's it's about creating a simple
life for yourself so you have you have
the energy you have the time you have
the other resources to contribute beyond
yourself in a meaningful way so yeah
don't don't ever stop contributing Thank
You Liz dive into these questions all
right cool we got quite a few we're
gonna start with Catherine crooks
question I think or maybe we won't we're
gonna start with control and I I've got
him I've got him here we're gonna start
with Tanya Olsen's question she says you
say show me your schedule and I'll show
you your priorities yeah we do say that
sometimes do you have any tips for rules
on how to schedule your day so that your
priorities are in fact your true
priorities right hmm
man um I don't know how to answer this
line I think of this profound truism to
say even more so about you know your
priorities aren't what you say yeah I
mean it's here's what it comes down to
for me those things that I scheduled in
my calendar the things that I schedule
first are my priorities and I treat my
calendar as gospel I do not allow other
things to cut in to those those times I
have set aside to work out that I have
set aside time to read that I've set
aside time to write or even if it's just
to hang out with Mariah and you know we
had planned dinner or something those
things are are held gospel so I do not I
do not let anything interfere with those
I guess I'm just having trouble because
I mean what I'm hearing her say here
Tanya right what I'm hearing Tanya say
here is she schedules her week but she
lets everything else get into the way I
mean but the biggest piece of advice is
will it's not about it's you don't have
to do anything magical here it's
it's just changing the way you approach
making your schedule and I've got to
tell a lot of people know so I can put
those priorities first I think that's so
important that the saying then know I'm
getting better at saying no and you got
to exercise that muscle because you're
probably bad at saying though right now
I think we all are because we're in this
culture of yes yes yes yes yes
that's the consumerist culture I'm gonna
say yes to everything not just the stuff
but like to every opportunity to every
every request every email and and before
you know it you're just plagued by
endless distractions so three things
before you real quick time so easy
number one is start your day with some
small victories now for me that can be
as something as simple as making my bed
and so I don't always got a bed first
when Beck's is there and so like we will
make the bed eventually but I like to
get a bed way before she'll you just
leave two or three hours after me and so
I'll get up within and start my day with
some other small victories so writing
exercise reading things that are our
priorities for me starting the day early
with two or three victories early on
that that sets up the momentum for the
day so I've already feel like I've
succeeded throughout that if you if you
have to wait all day to the end of the
night to work out you may not get around
to it right but if you've exercised
first thing in the morning like all
right I did that I feel really good
about it and who knows what I feel great
tonight maybe I'll exercise again or
I'll do some sort of stretching or yoga
or something and you'll have an
additional victory later on today but
start the day off with some some
victories number two is you want to
avoid distractions and part of that has
to do eight men well Ryan said to the
nose you have to be able to say no
frequently and that note can be as
simple as saying no to push
notifications on your phone yeah I mean
those things we have all these little
distractions throughout the day that
we're letting other people dictate our
schedule whether it's email or meetings
or text messages or pings or tweets or
Facebook status updates or instant
messenger or whatever it may be and we
have all these distractions we're
letting other people dictating before
you know it you're sitting in the
passenger seat of your own life yeah I
mean that's the worst thing you could do
is say yes to everyone scheduled in the
time that they want to take from you and
then look at your calendar and say oh
now where can I fit my priorities
I mean that is the exact opposite of the
way to to manage one schedule yeah yeah
and the third thing last thing I'll
recommend to you is develop better
habits I don't have a daily routine per
se but I do have daily habits and the
reason I'll have a daily routine is
because we're on the road quite a bit or
my life changes from day to day but I do
have habits that I must implement every
single day you know the first three that
I mentioned in the morning reading
writing and exercise those are three I
also do physical therapy every single
day but your habits really have to be in
line with your priorities or with your
values you need to figure out what those
habits are going to be and you need to
make them musts in your life instead of
shoulds it's so easy for us that I
should workout today or I should write
or I should contribute to my community
in a meaningful way but the truth is
that we can say I should do this we
don't get around to doing it when it
becomes a must when you have enough
leverage that then you're able to to
make that it's actually the decisions
already made for you when you have the
habit you're not making the decision
anymore you've already made the decision
you know you just have to execute on on
that habit yeah and don't be scared to
say no it is difficult you know I don't
want to make it sound easy but the
people in your life who love you and
care about you it would want you to be
happy they're gonna support you and
they're gonna understand when you say no
to something so you can say yes to
something else and the other thing I'll
just add real quick is you're probably
most people are I still am uncomfortable
with saying no and the only way I get
better at it is continuing to say no and
practicing so practice saying no and and
don't worry about what your your friends
and family think because if they love
you and want you to be happy they will
they will support you indeed they will
let's see now we actually do have a
question from Katherine all right
Katherine says hi guys
since I've started living a more
minimalist lifestyle I find myself
feeling some anxiety when I'm in
cluttered environments or visiting
friends and family who have a lot of
quote stuff is this normal that you guys
ever feel like this once you started
living intentionally with less I mean it
may be Nora III I think is this normal
was probably the wrong question to ask
right because I may be normal for you
it's not normal for me I don't judge
other people
when and it's funny when when I we were
on the road for our first book
minimalism live a meaningful life we
would stay at a lot of readers houses
and Ryan what's the first thing they
said as soon as we walked oh man no I'm
sorry you know my house isn't exactly
nice and tidy right now and I'm not a
minimalist I'm just a minimalist in
practicing but but please don't judge
all my stuff yeah and and what I've
learned is that that judgment is just a
mirror that reflects the insecurities of
the person who's doing the judging and
so really any time I feel anxiety about
other people's stuff it's really showing
my own insecurities and and and then I
have to start asking asking myself
deeper questions why do I feel so
insecure about this stuff why have I
given so much meaning this stuff why do
I care about what other people own but
because it's not directly affecting me
in any way now obviously if people were
buying a bunch of stuff and throwing it
at you that stuff starts affecting you
right but right now if you're just going
to someone else's space it's not really
that big of a deal just imagining like
you walking over and like someone hurl
in a kitchen sink at you or something no
III totally do get that anxious feeling
I think I can relate to this Catherine
for me it is the insecurity about what I
feel about my own home and I and you
know I started to think to myself like
what if I had to live in this home what
if I had to deal with this mess and it
starts to make me feel anxious like
because I started thinking about how I
have to clean and I had to get rid of
stuff and I'd have to you know do all
those things that I did when I did the
packing party but then I can quickly I
can quickly you know look at myself in
the mirror and say hey Ryan
this isn't your stuff and you don't have
to worry about how you're gonna tackle
this in fact you're here to spend time
with your friend or your family member
that you're here to see and for me to
give that thought and that anxiety any
more thought and let and let that stuff
stress me on it really takes away from
from that that moment in that time that
I'm trying to spend with that that
person that I care about I have been in
situations where like I'll go to a
certain family members house and they
smoke a lot and it stinks
and when I leave there I smell like a
tobacco factory like it's really really
bad so sometimes I will go there I'm
like you know what I'm just gonna
extinct and that's okay but other times
you know I might want to stop or hang
out with someone with this family member
before I go do something else and I
don't want to get you know I don't want
to smell like smoke before before I go
and do my my second thing that I have to
do so I will ask that family member if
they want to meet me for coffee or for
lunch I will ask them if I can remove
them from you know their house and we
can go somewhere else and I'm ready and
I'm very open with my with my family
member to about hey look you smoke and
when I leave there I stink really bad a
cigarette so I'd rather not hang out at
your place right now yeah and and I
think what you're talking about is let's
meet in a neutral environment right
you're not gonna feel intimidated in my
space because I don't own anything right
and and I'm not gonna feel anxious in
your space and you don't have to posit
it that way you can just say hey let's
meet at a coffee shop or I had really
prefer to grab lunch you know I haven't
eaten today or whatever and and that
will allow you to have sort of this
neutral ground yeah so you don't feel
that anxiety or that judgment and by the
way that family member like when you
know when I say hey look I really don't
want to smell like cigarette smoke I'd
rather not hang out at your place they
do not get offended because they
understand that okay yeah we smoke a lot
and Ryan doesn't wanna smell like
cigarette smoke and guess what they love
me and they want me to be happy so they
go out of their way to support me and I
do the same for them but of course you
know you know I mean look at all
Tomatoes that you would like for them to
stop smoking you know it's healthy for
them yeah but you don't say well I'm not
gonna be your friend if you're a smoker
I mean there are times where that's
necessary someone is is is doing
something that harms them and their
community or them and their friends and
you may have to distant this distance
yourself from them if it's a sort of
toxic relationship that's how you're
talking about here is you're not trying
to change that person you're just trying
to change the environment in which you
interact yeah and i'll say to like when
you're talking to someone about
something that like this is a great
example the smell of your house it is
offensive you don't want to just come
out and say something like that um what
I've learned is whenever you have to
have these tough conversations with
friends and family as long as you can
show them that you love them as long as
you can
show them that you support them that you
that you want them to be happy if you
can go out of your way to show them that
you care about them and respect them
that's the number one thing if they can
see that yes you're offended by the the
smell but you still respect them they're
going to react in a very positive way so
like the conversation I hope with this
family member it's it's it really was as
simple as hey I've got to go do
something else after you and I are
supposed to hang out and every time I
leave your house I smell like smoke a
lot that's okay I don't mind it usually
but I've got to go do something else can
we go hang out somewhere else and
they're like yeah absolutely cuz I'm not
saying well you know you have a tobacco
factory in your house and you stink so
bad and yeah yeah I mean you got to be
tactful with it and show that person
respect if you can show someone respect
then they will show it back to you for
the most part Keith callback asks I
frequently get asked for advice on
minimizing books and DVDs but when I say
there is nowhere to sell them and I
suggest donating that I'm often told I
might as well just hang on to them then
any suggestions for how to help my
friends find the leverage they need yeah
you probably don't want to help them
find the leverage they need I mean
here's what I mean by that if they're
not looking for it yeah it's like how do
you force your friends to play water
polo I mean if they're not if they're
not interested in doing that maybe they
can't swim then trying to force them is
is just going to drown them right and
and so I think that you're in the same
place if if they really want to let go
of stuff and then they need to find
leverage that's a different question but
if they want to hold on this stuff it's
not really your job for you to determine
what things they should or shouldn't
hold on to and I think that's important
for all of us letting go is is a highly
individual journey and even individual
in the sense like individual family unit
and so it starts with the one individual
quite often but then it can lead to the
whole family simplifying their lives but
that's the one individual unit the
family unit one household is another way
to put it but beyond that even even
within the household it's not about
forcing the other people it's about
leading by example and so I did the same
thing with all of my friends many of my
friends certainly aren't minimalists
some of them are but I think a lot of
them have have benefited from Ryan's
recipe and my recipe of letting go and
maybe they haven't let go of the same
stuff but it's helped them down that
same path toward something more
meaningful yeah I mean there's I'm if
you're asking her for advice on how you
could get leverage for getting rid of
your DVDs in your books yeah I mean I
would just if someone's asking you that
then like I would tell you Keith I'd say
hey man um how many times you're gonna
read those books how many times you're
gonna watch those DVDs like if that's
what you plan on doing with the rest of
your life like you might want to
reconsider what you're planning to do
with that time but Keith I would only
give that advice if someone was asking
for it I would never go to a friend or
film in rent Alma it sounds like three
is question they are asking for it
another thing another thing I thought
yeah you're right maybe I mean they're
not asking directly like give me
leverage right um but but there it
sounds like they're saying hey what can
I do he said here's a couple options and
they're finding excuses to hold on on
they're not asking for more advice or
leverage there is coming back with
excuses as to why they should hold onto
well I might as well hold onto it
because of X Y & Z yeah yeah
so yeah you got it you got to be careful
with that yeah I mean I think it's we
have to go into it without being
judgmental right absolutely and and and
here's the the best tip of what not to
do don't be passive-aggressive about it
like they don't respond to us man I'd
love to sit down here but they're all
these DVDs you're just throwing I mean
if you have a really good at like Ryan
and I could do that with each other
because it'd be hilarious buddy with
most people would be the most obnoxious
thing in the world
yeah and in fact it would only be
hilarious now the fact that we like
here's an example like I just when you
you went out to Ohio you left your
jacket back in LA and I went to go get
let your jacket your lights on you just
unpack the closet man and later you're
like yours
Mariah's stuff is it's behind my one
jacket is behind all variety like I call
Ryan and I'm like hey man I don't have
to dig through all this stuff to try to
find this jacket but like it would only
be funny now like because like we we are
on the same page if you're not on the
same page it seems as it seems like
you're arrogant or superior and and yeah
that's that's not a way to change
someone's mind yeah it's well that
doesn't show respect going back to that
whole thing it's like if you are coming
across as superior or mightier than now
then that's not showing one respect and
if someone if they feel like they are
not being respected they are certainly
not going to respect you
yeah yes indeed crystal asks what is the
best way to get the most out of
rejection how do I use disappointing
feedback to encourage myself to move
forward to the next pathway yeah I think
I think the pathway to success is
actually paved with rejections and so I
learned this early on when I first
started doing sales when I was like I
was 18 years old and and I think by 19 I
had figured out the the magic recipe -
yes was was a road paved with golden
knows and I remember doing cold calling
and having to like get you there was an
average like for every every tin knows
you got you would get one yes right and
sometimes you would and I would write a
Liat down I had tally sheet every single
day and some days you're like man I got
to my first yes after seven knows like
how awesome is that like my batting
average is improving significantly and
then after the Uniden you get the one
appointment and for every five
appointments you got you got one close
and so you're like okay well it takes 50
phone calls for me to get one clothes to
sail right that means I it takes 49
rejection
to get one acceptance and it becomes
odds at that point the best baseball
players in the world fail 70% of the
time think about that 300 batting
average is considered to be stellar
right think about a 400 batting average
which is unheard of except you know
maybe way back Ty Cobb there's something
that that means they still failed 60% of
the 60% of the time they struck out or
the fly out or whatever they got they
were out yeah and so I think the key is
to not allow that to force
procrastination you're like I failed
I'll just wait to do the next one no
that means you're one more no closer to
a yes and so I need to hurry up and get
these nose out of the way that was
always my philosophy and it still is my
philosophy now I'm gonna screw this up
when Ron and I go out on tour we have
nights where we we don't perform our
best we have other nights where we
absolutely kill it and I tell you that
ratio has improved significantly over
time yeah we have become yeah in the
same sense like the first time you ever
play first time you ever play baseball
you might strike out every single time
right and eventually you're gonna hit
the ball but then you're gonna get
better and you're gonna get better and
now I feel like we strike out with less
but we still have nice front legs strike
out
yeah and it's okay that they still
thinks that that failure to get to to
get to that success yeah I mean the the
only thing I might be able to like
squeeze out of this how to how to learn
from your failures question crystal is
just be clear on why you failed so if
it's if it's like sales or you know
batting whatever it may be like that's
that's kind of a numbers game right you
just got to keep going at it but let's
say you know there's a relationship you
have and it fails I don't you know
suggest you go out and fail 100
relationships but I would you know look
at that one failed relationship and get
clear on what was it that didn't that
didn't make this click was it we didn't
spend enough time with each other was I
being respected enough what was I not
respecting my partner enough whatever it
may be just get clear on why it didn't
work and then you know how to adjust
when you try it you know relationship
out again it can be a little dangerous
too right though because like
um you know that word jaded gets thrown
a lot for people who date like in their
30s right before tea everyone so jaded
and it would be very easy to hold on to
you know a lot of past bad interactions
with partners and stuff and let that
come through with other partners so you
know beware of that also but you know if
you have a partner where oh man they're
not you know they're always an hour late
and they're not calling you when they
say they will and some days you can't
get a hold of them and then you find out
they're they're cheating on you like
that's something you definitely want to
take note of and you know look for that
in other partners so I see I think
that's a great point Ryan with
especially with relationships I think
now like with Bex she's it's the best
relationship I've ever been and by far
and you know this and I've been in some
good relationships I've been in some
really bad relationships as you know
which will eventually make it maybe into
the next book and and I've been in
mostly mediocre relationships though
what do you think about it's like it
wasn't it wasn't awful but I wasn't
outstanding and those actually the in a
weird way there were still failures
because they they they failed in the
sense that I failed not the relationship
fail uh but they led to a success in the
sense that you know and and because of
that I don't even have to look at them
as failures anymore in that that same
sort of context I can look at them as
wow that was great for a particular
season and and we grew out of that
relationship and that's okay but the
lessons I learned from those previous
relationships I was able to carry those
forward and it's the reason my
relationship with Bex is so good now is
because we're able to talk about the
things and the failures from the past
the lessons that we've learned the times
we've struck out the the shitty
relationships the mediocre relationships
the good relationships where I have
failed where she has failed and get that
out in the open so we can avoid we can
avoid the pitfalls and pursue that which
we find meaningful absolutely all right
our next question I believe is from
Sally Russell yes it is
dee how do you let go of friendships
without appearing unkind or arrogant
particularly if you live in a small town
and you will cross paths with these
people again first off you're not gonna
be able to control how other people
you about you and I think it's one of
the so instead of letting go of just the
relationship the first thing that'll let
go of is is worrying about what their
interpretation is because just as you
can't you can't understand someone
else's intentions it's gonna be hard for
you to understand what emotions they
feel based on the life that you're
living I mean there are plenty of people
who think Ryan and I are one of the
words the unkind or arrogant and and I
have to be able to I think the key is
and this is the takeaway I would give
you Sally is you have to be able to look
yourself in the mirror and say is this
the best relationship for this period of
my life again going back to that
previous conversation you may have a
friendship a co-worker a boss a romantic
relationship acquaintance someone else
in the community you may have someone
where that relationship was really ideal
there are a lot of networking buddies I
had back in my 20s and it made sense for
what I was trying to do at the time but
those relationships don't necessarily
carry forward you know it's the there's
the old a Pithom for a reason for a
season and so there was a reason that we
went through this relationship together
maybe was a failure maybe I could learn
from it or maybe it was outstanding but
it's time to move on from that and and I
think the first thing that you need to
do is be able to look in the mirror and
say is this the right relationship for
me it does it align with my values and
if not then that's when you have to find
a way to let go of the relationship but
the first thing you have to let go of is
the worry about what other people think
about you because if you get caught up
in that it's just a death trap yeah yeah
I mean if you're asking for advice on
how to you know talk to a friend right
now that you have that you want to you
know stop being friends with I mean
that's that's gonna be difficult
conversations there's no doubt about
that
and I certainly don't have an easy
answer to make it easy what I'll say is
that you you have to have the
conversation though you have to have
that difficult conversation if you don't
then that friends gonna keep trying to
get a hold of you you're gonna keep
doing one a few things you're going to
ignore them you're gonna make excuses or
worse you're going to go ahead and
appease them and just say yes to them
and keep hanging out with them because
you're too
scared to have that hard conversation
with and that's not a good friend just
the I would hate if all you did was
appease me and you would hate if all I
did was appease you
yes that would be yes that would be a
horrible type of friend not a friendship
no that's not a friendship at all
so going back to I love how this keeps
coming up like show your friend respect
go out of your way to show that person
that you respect them you respect who
they are even if at the end of the day
maybe they're off you know I don't know
they're doing it they're having some
behavior you know that you don't approve
with at least show and you don't respect
their lifestyle but at least show them
that you respect their freedom and their
decision to do what they want to do with
their life and and explain to them that
what they do doesn't really align with
what you want to do and you think of a
time where you two did hang out and
maybe there was something where you
wouldn't saw a movie or whatever it
whatever it is you can say oh yeah you
know what we can go see a movie if you
wants you sometimes but you know going
to the bars and you know going out and
gossiping I don't know I'm just like
making up things here's why you wouldn't
want to be friends with this person but
you know when it comes to those things
yes like you were going to try to avoid
those activities more often I've had
friends in the past that I've literally
had the conversation with of hey every
time I talk to you it's a very negative
conversation nothing ever positive comes
out of what you and I talked about the
last you know few conversations we have
had has been really about what's going
on in your life and I try to you know
suggest ways to help and and and and I
also just sit there and listen but
hearing you making the same mistakes
over and over again and in not doing
anything to change it that is that is a
it's it's very negative and and I try to
avoid as many negative conversations as
possible I'm happy to be here for you
I'm happy to talk things through it but
I'm not gonna just sit here and listen
to your negative stories I'm really
trying to keep this broad because I
don't want like call anyone out so what
my point is is that having that tough
conversation like now when that but now
when I talk to that person because I
still do talk to them
as soon as it starts to go towards that
negative conversation I will simply say
hey this is really starting to go to
that negative route and you know I'm
happy to sit here and help if you want
but this doesn't feel helpful to me it
just feels like I'm hearing a bunch of
negativity and it'll totally redirect
the conversation and you and I do that
with each other even slowly all the time
I hey man I just can't use this
negativity right now I know we're like
this is really frustrating for both of
us who worked on this thing and the
podcast delete or whatever like we just
want happen like and we start bitching
about it and I'm Ryan we'll be like hey
you know like maybe they'll just like
put this off or they will discuss it
tomorrow when it's not like emotionally
charged or whatever the last thing that
I will say for Sally here is if if you
really love someone but it's a toxic
relationship sometimes the best way to
love them is from a distance and and it
doesn't mean you have to even s oh I
have there some people it's gonna be
impossible to have that conversation
with but it's it's possible to distance
yourself from them our friend Rob Bell
says you have to have a funeral for the
way you wish things were with your
friend and and because we can't change
those people right it's the thing I
always say you can't change the people
around you but you can change the people
around you meaning you can start
surrounding yourself with new people
that take up your time and that creates
that that distance from the people who
who were toxic and quite often that can
be the best way to love them all right
we're going over on time but I got at
least one more question that we we
should answer here because it was
upvoted Michelle Saunders asks give any
advice on conquering the fear of change
more specifically my husband and I
embrace minimalism and we desire to have
a simpler life in regards to home
ownership we cannot but we cannot seem
to pull the trigger to sell our
two-point-five story colonial home I
just imagined had like a four-foot floor
on the third Thursday that's not a floor
that's a cross I'm gonna recommend
actually adding on to the house
we were device for me to give well uh
okay let's see we've had this home for
28 years I was a large yard in-ground
pool by the way there's nothing wrong
with those things and in ground pool I
mean I've got friends of that and it's
pretty great I wish I would have one as
a kid I had a an aunt that we would go
out to once or twice a year at once
twice a year out in Germantown Ohio it's
like they owned a farm and and right
outside of Dayton and we would go there
and play there in-ground pool it was
really great awesome
yeah yeah there's nothing wrong with
with owning that but but here here's
where it comes I add here that it is
quite empty now you use that word and it
may be physically empty but my guess is
you mean sort of existentially and empty
as well spiritually empty yeah
functionally empty as well it's empty
because we found no happiness in the
thing in things and we spend our time
traveling and experiencing things that's
great so the house doesn't align with
your values anymore for a reason for a
season right it sounds like the season
has passed it sounds like you're wearing
a winter coat in the summer now right
and it's just too much
it has outlived our usefulness but we
fear the unknown ie what if we don't
like a new place do we make the wrong
decision etc etc etc we dream of a
smaller place less costs and maintenance
but we continually stole so I mean it's
well if to me what stands out yeah
what's that it sounds like she has more
leverage right now to keep the house and
get rid of it mm-hmm and and here's the
weird problem she feels some discontent
but it's not enough pain then she says
there's no happiness here but no
happiness doesn't mean pain no happy
this means a lack of happiness right and
and you need to get beyond that no
happiness you're in by the way you're
starting the experience pleasure on the
other side of it but Ryan you said she
doesn't have the leverage she doesn't
have the leverage because she's not
experiencing enough pleasure outside of
the home and also you haven't figured
out like where where do I want to end up
you you figure out what you don't want
what you don't want is usually not that
compelling it can be if it pisses you
off enough but this house doesn't piss
you off and so you need to find and or
to find something that's compelling it's
not what you don't want we know you
don't want the house anymore
what are you gonna run to we don't want
you running away from the house just yet
because you had is comfortable what is
safe I if I were in your shoes I'd set a
deadline yeah because right now she's
running to something that she may not
like in her head right and you want to
run to something that you are going to
love and and that means the experience
the place and again it doesn't mean that
you'll love it forever right Ryan and I
just moved out to Los Angeles and it's
for a reason for a season the reason is
that's where people go to tell stories
the season is yeah we're 36 year old
right now and it may be till we're 37 or
40 or 50 or say you we don't know what
that season looks like for us right now
but we know it's the right choice right
now but realizing that everything is
ephemeral everything when you when you
look on a long enough timeline so you
look back he'll say wow that was a great
season but it's time for you to change
it's time for you to shed that winter
coat and you need a deadline and for me
you know I don't know enough about your
situation but if you have the house pay
it off or if you're not upside down on
the house which it sounds to me like
you're probably not then you can go
ahead an put it up for sale as soon as
you have figured out where you're
running to and I would give myself
personally three months of crazy
research where do I want to go it's in
the same state same city or do I want to
move to a different state different city
large or smaller maybe I want to move to
a different country for a while maybe I
want to travel the world for a year what
is going to make you excited to get up
every day not that it's not going to be
difficult a lot of is gonna be difficult
especially if you're traveling or you're
you're in a new place that's gonna be
much more difficult than staying where
you are but that difficulty that
friction is what's going to allow you to
grow and also help you feel most alive
yeah I totally agree set a deadline
you've got to find something to run
towards that you absolutely love because
that's you are in a comfortable spot
right now it sounds like your home is is
beautiful and you want something that's
just as beautiful then great find
something just as beautiful and run
towards it but sitting at home and in
creating all these excuses
just continue to sit and not sell your
house that that is that is not giving
you the right leverage so set a deadline
find something you love and and start
getting leverage to leave the place
what's your name brother hi welcome to
the bonus round were you from originally
a Grand Rapids Michigan
oh nice another great Midwestern city
yeah yeah oh so my question is you get a
little close to that mic if you don't
mind I know you're super tall what do
you like six nine so you take it off
that's all right it's a microphone it
drops it's been dropped a million times
I'm sure there you go there you go dude
okay thanks for the assessor yeah so my
question is what do you guys believe is
the common good and how does minimalism
contribute to that yeah yes so so that's
a great question by the way you very
rarely hear me say that all of the
previous questions were the crap
compared to that question Lucas here's
why I rarely say that because it's
usually say I caught myself a long time
ago I would go back like I watching game
tapes and like listen to old interviews
we did to see how awful it was and like
I would say that after every question oh
great question they throw you a softball
like hey where does minimalism oh what a
great question and I realize like I was
just saying mr. Lyte to fill space kind
of like I'm doing right now no and so
you said you say common good yeah okay I
would say greater good and and and so I
tend to think of greater good as in how
do we maximize the ideal life for the
most number of people
Ryan earlier talked about how it's not a
perfect life it's not an easy life it's
a simple life and
and when when you simplify your life I
find quite often you start to figure out
what's actually important and what's
going to contribute to the the greater
good and what does that mean greater
good it just means beyond myself it
means I have to get my life in order
before I can start to try to contribute
in some meaningful way whether that's
something like going to the house of
bread over in West Dayton and
contributing to to people who just need
food or it's finding ways to contribute
a message that may simplify people's
lives the the greater good is how do we
maximize the happiness meaning happiness
and meaning in people's lives and I
think it's a landscape so so if you
think of a landscape there are peaks and
valleys right and so the the peak of my
life might be slightly different from
the peak of your life like what is
maximized for me might be different for
you and I think it's different for each
individual person in this room and and
that means the ideal happiness or ideal
life is going to look slightly different
for each person so the greater good is
an amalgamation of of everyone who's in
here everyone who's listening to this
and how do we try to maximize or improve
their life and so how do we minimize to
maximize this sort of a way and here's
the problem we're stuck in all the
valleys of that landscape right now and
minimalism teaches us that there's a
different place from these valleys we've
been we've been blanketing our lives
with stuff to try to make us happy Ryan
talked earlier about filling the void
with stuff and it just widens the gap it
makes that that valley in the landscape
wider and it makes it harder to find
these peaks and valleys there's
something said we're we're in a lot of
pain and I think we try to medicate a
lot of times with stuff but we also try
to medicate with with with drugs so
we're in Montgomery County right now
this is the overdose capital of the
United States and I don't know what the
solution to that is and so I feel very
lucky
to not have that addiction myself but I
also feel very sympathetic because I
know a lot of people in my own personal
life who who do have that addiction and
I don't know what the overall solution
is other than going out and helping the
people that I can't help and it doesn't
mean fixing everyone's life but I think
living a simpler life allows us to
reprioritize what what our actual
priorities are and maybe just maybe
suffer less
as a result yeah I'm I feel like I'm
giving the same answer to different
questions
minimalism helps us to realize like we
don't need nearly as much as what we
desire and once one has that true
realization of like wow like I can just
be happy with the things I have now I
don't have to have a new car every
couple years I don't have to have a nice
big home I don't have to go on that
fancy vacation every I mean once some
once one realizes like oh wow like I
actually I need to focus more on my
priorities rather than on stuff it opens
the door for people to contribute so
like I felt I was trying to think of
something pithy the Pythias thing I've
come up with is minimalism can help
someone fill the void with contribution
towards their community rather than
stuff thank you thanks Lucas Christian
can I can I get a hug
oh yeah you can I know you guys are
rings laughs yeah come on man
is six-nine
[Applause]
all right we got time for one more
action we don't have time but we'll make
time for one more
what's your name brother thank you very
much I'm Nick I'm from Columbus Ohio so
not too far from here I'm a student here
currently though yeah I heard a no H out
there somewhere wrong school Ryan we
actually did that in our columbus stuff
this year and it was it felt very
cult-like so I'm currently pursuing a
degree in mechanical engineering
pursuing my bachelor's and you know as
an engineer once I get out I'll have a
good-paying job it's not really part of
it but so somebody who as an engineer I
feel like we have a lot of stress on us
to produce to innovate and to come up
with a lot more stuff sure come up with
tons of things and we in my opinion are
throwing more of these wants or desires
into society fidgets spinners exactly
there you go
so I guess in your guys's eyes how could
I as an engineer promote more of a
minimalistic society yeah I have the
perfect idea for you dude
biodegradable cell phone um
biodegradable TV biodegradable laptop
like no I we need stuff man like we have
a microphone I've got a laptop there is
an opportunity costs it comes along with
producing those things if I was an
engineer man like that's where my head
would be maybe you don't start with a
cell phone maybe it's you know think of
something that we view as disposable and
then we're constantly throwing out and
filling the landfill with with things
that are going to be there for hundreds
of years centuries and think about how
you can help minimize that that that
waste so I think it's awesome you're an
engineer I think it's awesome that you
are getting into this minimalist mindset
so it's like how can you how can you
take these simple ideas and apply them
towards the things that you make and
you're gonna get a ton of pushback tuned
because the world that you're gonna go
into it is how can we create a one how
can how can we make someone feel like
they need this thing and I think you can
you know kind of marry the two ideas
with with going down you know the road
something like that yeah I think you
don't have to be part of the problem I
think it's easy to become part of the
problem so I'll give you a couple
examples so first off Ryan and I refuse
to do ads on our podcast they're 100%
advertisement free but it's there's a
weird irony here like if we decided to
ads on our podcast we'd be rich right
now like literally like like seven
figures a year rich that's how many
people it's one of the biggest podcasts
in the world which is a really weird
thing to say and so the the path of
least resistance for me would be well
yeah that makes sense we all like money
and here's the thing there's nothing
wrong with money in fact yeah money can
well here so money doesn't solve all of
our problems but it does solve all of
our
any problems right the weird thing about
that though is almost all of our money
problems are self-inflicted I grew up
really poor and thought well hey we're
not happy because we don't have money
and then I became rich in my 20s and
realized that like well hey wait a
minute the reason I wasn't contented
earlier was we had a lot of money
problems that were self-inflicted
and then I had money problems in my 20s
they were self-inflicted and in fact I
was technically more broke when I was in
when I was rich because I had this thing
called debt and and I had a lot of
people who would be willing to give me
enough well enough money so that I could
continue to pay them back with lots of
interest and and so in a weird way I was
just reproducing the problem on a
grander scale and as an engineer you
have that opportunity to reproduce a
problem and I think advertisements are a
huge part of the problem in our society
and so that's why we won't get behind
that is there a way to do it ethically
and and and sustainably and and and do
good advertise yeah probably but it's
just not in line with our ethos and so
we're not gonna talk about what mattress
we sleep on at night or what a shaving
whatever podcasts wedgy free underwear
anyway I think never tending sorry that
was a good idea and I think that that
you can choose to create Ryan and I
create you can create as engine as an
engineer in a way that is sustainable
and aligns with your values is it going
to be difficult hell yeah it is but
everything worth doing is difficult man
makes your question Nick thank you very
much
have a hug too oh yeah yeah
hi Josh and Ryan this is Heather from
San Diego and I am calling to answer
Riley's question from your most recent
podcast episode called toxic she seemed
like she really was interested in
minimalism and wanted to actually put it
evangelize it without trying to convert
people and I think that's really
honorable and I just wanted to give my
experience I became a minimalist about a
year ago from listening to your guys's
podcast and I had already had a YouTube
channel at this point and what I did is
I started to channel my interest in
minimalism
into my YouTube channel and people
started to find my channel even more
because they were searching for
minimalism so I feel like if you don't
want to just shout into the void and try
to convert people to minimalism try to
convert your friends to minimalism
having a youtube channel or just a blog
like you guys do is a way to put that
message out there and have your audience
be people who are actually interested in
hearing about it and incorporating it
into their lives so Riley you seem like
you're really confident talking in front
of people you might be really confident
talking to a camera you seem like ever
really fun the personality I feel like
you might do really well starting a
YouTube channel about middle of
minimalism where people will search and
actually be wanting to hear what you
have to say and it's really great and
really fun and I will be your subscriber
so I hope this helps and have a great
day
hi this is Melissa I currently live in
Hawaii and I am calling after listening
to your podcast and Ottawa and I had a
suggestion for the young lady in high
school who is working 16 hour weekends
and 60 hour work weeks during the summer
honey you can do half that as long as
you also work the same amount those four
years in college so if you work
eight-hour weekends in high school and
eight-hour weekends in college right and
you work 30 hour week and high school
and
thirty hour weeks and college you can
cut that time in half and still leave
college debt-free and when you're in
high school you can take that extra time
and apply for scholarships so I hope
that this message reaches you and take
care Mahalo
this is Kristin in North Carolina I have
a suggestion for parents who want to
encourage children to donate and
minimize especially in light of the
Christmas season where there is an
expectation of getting a lot of presents
and bringing new items into the
household put a laundry bin or basket
under the Christmas tree and say it's
from Santa and that you have to give in
order to receive it becomes almost a
game such that children are encouraged
to place in the basket toys they no
longer play with or close they along no
longer wear such that Santa will then
bring them new presents they learn the
value of letting go of old items that
will go to other children in need and
also will help parents declutter in the
process
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without your
[Music]
team
[Music]
you
[Music]